Despite mostly taking place in the far, far
off reaches of outer space, Thor: Ragnarok
hits very close to home for many Marvel fans.
Like most films from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, it's full of some pretty deep cuts
into Marvel's comic pages.
Here are a few Easter eggs you'll find in
Ragnarok, and of course, there are Hulk-sized
spoilers ahead.
(Hulk smashing)
Throg
The first and most obvious reference to Marvel
Comics' strange history is when it's revealed
that Loki once turned Thor into a frog.
That really happened, for a couple of issues
at least, during one of Loki's many attempts
to overthrow Asgard.
It all starts in Thor #364, and winds its
strange way through "Thor, Frog of Thunder"
meeting a bunch of rats, escaping death by
alligator, playing a game of Frogger across
a road, and having a run-in with a psychic-flute-playing
Morlock in the sewers.
While a completely different "Throg" would
eventually take up the mantle after Thor reverted
back to his hunky Asgardian form, it's such
a weird part of Thor history that it may just
be one of his most iconic tales.
Bi-Beast & company
Throg isn't even the most unexpected character
show up in MCU continuity over the course
of Ragnarok.
Sure, weirdos like Howard the Duck and Cosmo
the space-dog are strange, but it rarely gets
more bizarre than the four characters whose
enormous busts are positioned around the Grandmaster's
tower, all of whom were presumably champions
at one point.
First, there's Bi-Beast, a robot who bears
a pair of impossibly-stacked faces, and who
made his first appearance in The Incredible
Hulk #169.
You'll also find a bust of Ares, Marvel's
very own god of war who first appeared in
Thor #129, and another character whose power
seems far too enormous to comfortably slip
into a Marvel film.
Third, there's Beta Ray Bill, a deer-like
alien with the same powers as Thor, and a
powerful ally to Asgard who first appeared
in Thor #337.
Finally, there's Man-Thing, a magical scientist-turned-swamp
monster who is definitely from Earth, and
the only one among these champions to not
have a special connection to Hulk or Thor.
As the garbage dump of the universe, Sakaar
really sees some diversity.
But let's head back to that crazy space-deer
for a second…
Exiled Asgardians
By the end of Ragnarok, we have a bunch of
homeless Asgardians floating around in a spaceship,
which is a scene that might seem a little
familiar to true Thor fans.
Way back in Thor #337, a Korbinite alien named
Beta Ray Bill is in a similar situation when
Thor finds him floating around on a ship called
Skuttlebutt, which itself bears some resemblance
to the Asgardian's escape vehicle in Ragnarok.
He, too, is a champion of his people and in
search of a new home after Surtur destroyed
their planet.
If Bill's giant bust on Sakaar's display of
deceased champions is any indication, his
story didn't end nearly as positively as it
did in the comics.
Contest of Champions
Once on Sakaar and enslaved by the Grandmaster,
Thor gets the rundown on the whole gladiatorial
arena thing, courtesy of a Willy Wonka-styled
trip through a horror tunnel, and an explanation
from the Grandmaster himself, who refers to
his staged fights as a "contest of champions."
Not coincidentally, Contest of Champions is
the exact title of a 1982 Marvel miniseries
starring the Grandmaster, who challenges Death
to a duel, using Marvel's best and brightest
as their champions.
Their heroes included Iron Man, She-Hulk,
and…
Arabian Knight.
They weren't all winners.
Scrapper 142
While Thor's original lady captor isn't ever
given a formal name aside from "Scrapper 142",
she's generally referred to as a "Valkyrie."
There's some precedent for both names, even
if neither are totally correct.
Marvel's Valkyrie, or rather an imposter version
of her created by the Enchantress, plays a
major role in a one-shot tale in The Incredible
Hulk #142.
The Valkyrie in Ragnarok isn't the one and
only Valkyrie, and the number 142 is a pretty
big hint that she's just borrowing the name
for now.
So, where's the real Valkyrie?
It's possible that we see Marvel's original
heroine being speared during Scrapper 142's
flashback battle with Hela.
Given that the word "valkyrie" also applies
to a whole regiment of warrior women, it's
safe to assume that the name probably gets
passed around a lot.
Infinity Gone-tlet
One of the most confounding things in MCU
mythology is the presence of the Infinity
Gauntlet.
While it's become the locus of absolute power
over the course of Marvel's films, it made
its first appearance in the original Thor,
as a treasure stored safely in Asgard.
While it was mostly a throwaway reference
to some intense, cosmic Marvel stuff, it led
many eagle-eyed Marvel fans to wonder why
there was more than one Infinity Gauntlet
floating around the MCU, since Thanos clearly
had one also.
The entire scenario is retconned in one line
when Hela calls the Gauntlet in Asgard out
as a fake.
Problem solved, right?
But why did Odin keep a dummy glove in his
basement?
Was it a decoy?
Did he think it was real?
Or did he just pick it up at Comic Con and
thought that it really tied the room together?
The world will never know.
King Kirby
Oldschool comic geeks could tell from Ragnarok's
early trailers that the film would be drawing
very heavily from the art style of Jack Kirby,
one of Marvel's original architects, and the
original artist of Thor.
A vast majority of the costume designs seen
on Sakaar were based on Kirby's drawings of
Celestials and other strange alien gods, but
one thing was pulled directly from Kirby's
comic pages: the enormous drawings on the
walls of the Grandmaster's viewing chambers.
The guy's got amazing taste.
And of course, nobody missed Thor's original
creator, Stan Lee, as Sakaar's shaky-handed
barber, right?
And speaking of Marvel's many creators, there's
also cousin Carlo, played by Steven Oliver.
He may be a bit of a throwaway character,
and he's most definitely melted all over the
Grandmaster's floor, but he was named after
artist Carlo Pagulayan, who illustrated part
of Marvel's Planet Hulk storyline, which served
as the inspiration for much of Ragnarok.
Fake Thor
In what might be one of the most unexpected
cameos in all of the MCU, we're treated to
Matt Damon and Sam Neill.
Damon and Neill are playing the parts of Loki
and Odin respectively, in Loki-Odin's very
own self-aggrandizing play.
The actor playing fake-Thor is a little harder
to pin down, because he looks a lot like Chris
Hemsworth.
The reason for that is that he's played by
another Hemsworth: Chris' brother Luke.
Although it's brief, it's a pretty cleverly
cast, handsomely Hemsworthy Easter egg.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!